so they say that this was the
inspiration for Walt Disney to make
Disneyland maybe should be extra nice to
her today hurry up and finish the food
hi I'm a turtle fall is officially here
[Music]
what's up leave nation happy days seven
here onboard boat we are heading for
Copenhagen today Denmark Nina had a
great sleep slept like 10 hours last
night you know being a bastard she's
feeling very full - she said she's only
gonna have coffee for breakfast
I don't I don't find that I don't buy
that but we'll see what happens we're
gonna go eat and then get ready and get
off the boat see some Denmark whoo
it is hell getting us some coffee but I
feel bad for her that she's so foolish
just won't eat anything maybe she'd be
extra nice to her today what do you guys
think let me know in the comments all
right this is Round one for me
Nina's just got hot water shooter her
word well well well what do we have here
oh that's a plate full of food I just
not that bad that's pretty healthy too
close I do not want to have an angry
wife that is for sure
toast mushrooms vegetables hockey all
right
turn up the key to shooting
peach chili
still finishing up around 1:00 all right
it's time to get off the boat
[Music]
so we made it on another hop-on hop-off
bus but when I can stay as long this
time
and it is not gonna pass it so first
stop we're looking for a very famous
restaurant it's been around for a
hundred years something like that or
more 200 years on enough they make the
famous Danish sandwiches s'mores burger
you pronounce it Nina likes to try new
food all the time
so we're gonna find it for her and get
started it's just past noon so good time
to eat some lunch and hopefully we find
the place soon
[Music]
all right we found it restaurant
Schuneman since 1877 I said 100 years
right - dude they're inside okay
nobody's just sitting outside all right
we found it
[Music]
well sad news Nina's getting everything
on they do they're fully booked until
3:30 so we couldn't make it happen for
Nina she's sad she's okay
we're gonna go find some food somewhere
else I have backup planes oh that's what
good planning does too bad they're
famous but you know what kind of smelled
in there it was really hot in there too
I thought you smelled pretty good in
there but it was really hot and they
only had dark beer so let's find a
better place yeah
[Music]
look what we found what do you think
Nina concealing it Nina's feeling it
they have the pumpkin spice latte which
I'm going to do and they have a pic and
caramel latte the Nina's gonna do so
excited to try fall is officially here
[Music]
nice this is the pumpkin spice latte
Nina loves the Starbucks mug Nina just
wants huge mugs
[Music]
they're like life is a limit
[Laughter]
[Music]
so in Copenhagen they're famous for
their small swimming open-faced
sandwiches the most famous one is the
smoked salmon hate smoked salmon but
we're going to get one phoniness you can
give it a shot
oh look at that meatball holy cow that's
a crazy meatball here is our lunch and
Nina's gonna try the beer
oh wow so we came for Nina this Mars
bride smoked salmon
how was it
decent all right try that try the try
that meatball - this is crazy meatball
let's just bread
oh that's the meat but what's this thing
on top
oh I get it now I get it now okay I
understand good
let's call this one the Danish
open-faced sandwiches all right that was
a crazy filling lunch how are you
feeling I am feeling full that beer was
a special filling we are going to work
our way through the tours shopping area
and had to Tivoli Gardens which has
400,000 different flowers and I think
Nina's gonna enjoy it I hope it's gonna
enjoy it
Nina loves nature Nina loves all things
nature she loves animals she loves all
dogs and animals she loves watching
people's vegetable gardens grow she
loves looking at flowers and so
hopefully she enjoys fingers crossed the
two Polly Gardens
[Music]
typically we made it hey Nina you're
extra short I am too
[Music]
so they say that this was the
inspiration for Walt Disney to make
Disneyland you can see there's like Taj
Mahal Mount Everest behind we got crazy
rides back there restaurants flowers
gardens they could see how this could be
an inspiration for Disney I like it
[Music]
it's interesting just kind of like
Disney there's different lands we're in
China right now there's different themes
different rides different stores it's
like a little mini Disney but in Denmark
if it wasn't raining we'd probably go on
some of these things it's cool just goes
to show you you can get inspiration from
anywhere Howard Schultz got the idea for
Starbucks from going to cafes and Italy
they said we need this in North America
you know Disney came here and said I
need to make something like this in
California so when you guys are going
away you might get inspired bring
something back put your own stamp on it
but you can get inspiration from
anywhere
[Music]
all right the rain continues and we
continue forward next stop we're gonna
try to catch our hop-on hop-off bus and
then head to where we heading to
oh the market where they have legendary
hot dogs
yeah meme is hungry so we're gonna get
her a hot dog and then if we still have
time we're gonna climb the church stairs
but give you a good view of the city so
so you can catch our bus arriving make
an executive decision change plans the
hop-on hop-off bus stops and misery
yeah
34:14 so if we go to the hot lush place
of the church
I'm gonna miss our bus we have to walk
in the rain on the end of the cruise
port which is not interested
[Music]
we want to get one
[Music]
you didn't want to get wet what make you
happy
so sanitation device access terminal
maybe see the
think the bus is the Little Mermaid
statute this is a Hans Christian
Andersen's
about it I like that
leave why something but so like my son
delivery and then walk back to the boat
get on board get drive change my size I
got cheese my socks are your side that's
a good good Peter so five toes shoes
awesome the chocolate fix up when it's
raining there it is
little are made so we hopped off speaks
right by the bus stop and then west
still here
next up is appreciation for doing
ooh we made it back on the boat it's
very exciting
Nina how you feeling Nina likes being
inside both of our feet are soaked and
frozen so it's good to be back on we're
gonna head back to the cabin I have to
record some videos for you guys you
can't go through here and Nina's going
to get some food are you gonna do get
comfortable first priority is getting in
a comfortable I like that this is gonna
be the background that I use of the
video port of Denmark Copenhagen for the
belief videos
[Music]
all right successfully film is good we
are hungry we're gonna get some food
scene is very hungry
[Music]
okay dinner's done nina is stuffed stuff
no we actually skipped the dessert today
so that we can go up to the buffet and
get one dessert instead of our usual
dinner dessert and then buffet hazards
I'm hoping for I am hoping for some
amazing cobbler something that I could
put some ice cream and caramel sauce on
and Nina's hoping for one Nina wants
some alcohol let's see what we can find
okay moment of truth time to see the
dessert it'll be good this is it no they
have something they have it and
blueberry cobbler it doesn't matter that
this almost is a keyword depends a
caramel
and there is the perfect dessert ready
look look look oh yeah huh yeah I mean
where'd you get beef and barley soup
nice okay back to the room oh wait how
about your drink right now we're out
there now okay now give Nina her drink
now okay we're back gonna enjoy the ice
cream you still work on the book and
towel and I'm all turtle I've never seen
the turtle before look at that look at
this guy
hi I'm a turtle initially I'm gonna make
these then every day when I come home
from work there a list of acts
[Music]
all right finish the that was a lot of
food
I had to down it because Nina noticed in
the calendar but there's Latin dancing
for one hour that we missed half of
already so like hurry up and finish the
food so I hustled the down that I feel
kind of gross but Nina is wearing heels
so she's surprisingly tall as you can
tell in this video right now let's go
find let's know this way so we can get
our Latin dancing on yeah
[Music]
we've danced a couple songs already
Lina's taking a break with the drink of
the day she doesn't know what's coming
she just expects it to be good
special things that happen to you and
they just might need let's get another
drink
what is it this time margarita what kind
where why are we choosing wait that's
not mine am I having one have a sip
about you're having two
there you go he only gets two margaritas
Nina made a surprise trick
well not surprise he told me you're
going but she made a trip to get food it
is 9:20 at night and we've got great
chicken in holy cow look at all this
spring rolls pizza and cookies
chili
[Music]
book so the book is pretty much finished
just have to figure out some of the
details like acknowledgments dedications
do I want to do all that you know do I
want to have a table of contents all
those kind of minor things that go along
with the book but are potentially
important but not a ton oh we're putting
together and the last step that I'm
working through right now is
proofreading yeah typos spelling
mistakes grammar errors all that fun
stuff so tomorrow's a day at sea I might
be able to get through the whole thing
we'll see it's the goal anyway I have
some videos to record tomorrow for the
channel and gonna spend some time spell
check and proofread but I think by the
time I get home with the flight and an
extra day at sea this should be pretty
much done whoo right it's exciting I'm
excited I'm very excited
[Music]
so just past mid-1989
is passed out on the bed by working
but for you guys yes excited thank you
guys again for joining me for another
edition of you have an amazing weekend I
believe in you but you need to believe
in yourself
whatever
or if I just love sec